[Music]
Hillary Clinton failed the Democratic
Party two years ago but she's been
determined to remain in the public eye
ever since now the New York Times
editorial board is fed up with it in an
opinion piece board member michelle
coddle complains about clinton's
masterclass in distraction she says
Clinton's recent stunts her attacks on
civility for example are diluting the
party's message and could cause them to
suffer more defeats at the ballot box in
short Hillary please go away for just a
few minutes Dave Rubin hosts the Rubin
report and he joins us tonight what do
you make it a great to see you by the
way
good to see you one of the benefits of
being in Los Angeles is you're on the
set what do you make of Hillary Clinton
with I mean she is still the standard
bearer of the party isn't she she was
the last nominee yeah I mean look this
line about civility that we can no
longer be civil with our political
opponents opponents think about what
that really means I mean just word it
differently we should start being
uncivil right that's what she's really
saying so what aren't what does that
really mean hunt them down in in
restaurants find in elevators go to
their jobs should we stop them on the
road I mean where does this go the thing
that we have in America is that we can
do this every night you Tucker Carlson
can argue with someone about something
politically s and it doesn't get violent
and you wrap it up at the end of the day
and you go home and you do it again the
next day stability is all we have and
they're making it very clear and this is
something I say this as someone that was
on the left my whole life I never voted
I think one time in my life I have voted
for a Republican which was Mike
Bloomberg at his third term in New York
City a long time ago and that's really
hazy Republican so I say this is someone
that's been trying to call it out from
what I considered my side for a long
time it's like guys let's let's rein
this back in a little bit because what
is after civility and and I think we
both know what it is and it's pretty
dangerous I wonder if she does I think
they've realized that they've lost
control of the party the the Clinton
machine doesn't have control of the
party anymore the party's going through
this democratic socialist or socialist
Democrat whatever this thing they'll
drop the Democrat parts yeah
and she's trying to grab anything that
will make her feel relevant again
and she's not really that relevant and
in a weird way she has to get out away
for this other thing to to take over not
that I think the other thing is great
because believe me I actually think this
other thing the more far left-wing in
the party is much worse I take Hillary
Clinton any day over some of these
people were gonna look back and go man
the Clintons were the good old days and
I say this I voted for Bill Clinton
twice ok so Hillary they're losing
control and that's why I recalled her
when there when they go low we kick them
all of these things these are not
coincidences right this is not you know
Maxine Waters find them and and hunt
them down or whatever she said and Cory
Booker did the same thing and I've seen
articles about you you know fine Tucker
Carlson in a restaurant he's so upset
that he won't be able to go to a
restaurant and it's like if that's where
we're at we will look back and go man we
really screwed up the most beautiful
experiment that has ever been done I
agree in in world history about how do
you get different people from all over
the world to come together and live
together we've done it right here and it
doesn't mean it's perfect for everyone
it doesn't mean that there aren't some
racists it doesn't mean that we have
class issues and and economic issues and
all sorts of things but if we don't pull
back this thing it might be much worse
and it will be much worse faster than
anyone gets totally right because it's
more fragile than we acknowledge yeah
Dave Rubin great to see you
likewise my very much